all right so i call you hop yes
all right hop hop where are you from
originally where'd you grow up
hattiesburg mississippi hattiesburg and
uh
tell me about your childhood you had
both your parents growing up yeah both
my parents my mother was a beautician my
father was a construction worker
he had moved us out here from
mississippi in the early 50s
he we had had problems with the clue
club clan back in mississippi
uh coming in our yard attempting to kill
me so my mother wanted her children and
herself out of mississippi so he came
out here
and created his own construction company
um
and and spent a lifetime hustling and
and
uh and working saving his money
he lived well he did real good in his
profession and my mother as a beautician
did well
and how would you describe your
childhood wonderful wonderful my mother
uh spoiled me as i was the only boy so
she spoiled me to death she
she dressed me and taylor made suits and
diamonds and
kept me in cadillac's and um and the
women that she
that was her clients babied me and
spoiled me and some of them sexed me
as a child and created me that i am
today
so it's not really in your family but
you were introduced to it
yes when i was about 16 years old i had
a
a child by a girl that was younger than
me a couple years younger than me
and uh i decided to leave home when i
left home i went to her
parents home to visit her let her know i
was leaving
growing up and she told me that uh
if i gave her 90 days she put me in
cadillacs and
meets and stuff and she did she did
at the time i didn't know anything about
hohen and pimping
but she gave it to me she grew me taught
me how to talk to women
how to deal with women this is a common
story yeah i've heard from a lot of the
gentlemen that you do i don't i don't
know any player who
women didn't turn out you know those
guys that claim that they got it
naturally was born with the gift
and stuff like that were frauds to me
you know
every time that i saw anyone that was
really good at pimping they were good
because the women taught them how to be
good at pimping what what is it about
because these are all african-american
women what is it about the culture that
that makes this a thing i mean
what is it about the when i was a
younger cat
it was you know people were poor black
people were poor they didn't have
anything
the only thing that black women could do
to really enhance the man that they
loved
was the whole cell they bodies and stuff
like that or to be called homecoming
hostesses
for males uh i've had a ray of different
women of all races
in my life i just showed you a
photograph of the of a lady with me
and she was indian she became one of the
best con playing females
in the history of america
but what is it about the black
culture that makes it the woman's job to
build up the man well in our culture
in our culture the woman was always
there during slavery times up until
the 70s women was always there to
protect the black man from
slave master and from slavery or the
milk bad
and male treatment of slaves and so
she took on the responsibility when when
modern times came
she took on responsibility to take care
of her man and her children
you think that's where it stems from it
does wow for a matter of fact
if you're from mississippi you would
know right yes yes for sure
that's interesting i uh because that
that's the one part of the puzzle that
really doesn't seem to make sense like
the women are
always grooming the men
teaching them how to do this right so
that they can give them all their money
right well it becomes a unity thing
among our people and my girls and i
we're all a team and we respect it like
that and i'm there
because i'm i'm that male element that
they need
so to provide because it becomes
essential
for them to have the male element in
their life what are you what are you
providing to this
i provide security i provide information
intelligence and
knowledge they know how to talk to a man
how to treat a man
how to please a man and they can't get
that from another female
until that female becomes groomed as a
whole
but you're not you're not uh forcing
them you're not oppressing them
you're not doing anything that's
something outside of pimping
yeah so you're in real life yeah in real
life i don't know about the fantasy
books that people read well there's many
different styles i've learned but women
women tend to that's really in the game
choose the man that they want to be with
and not be forced those guys out in the
street forcing women kidnapping women
making them do things
is the reason that the players have this
uh
slavery thing you know what i mean the
human trafficking yeah human trafficking
yeah all the new laws
it's more of a problem to play real
players and real hoes
because they don't want to be trapped up
in that face that my kind of time for a
profession that's
really uh a lover's profession so the
game the
the way the game is played today is is a
an altered version of what you've yes
it's crazy it's insanity yeah because
not now it seems like the women are
totally been being taken advantage of
right you haven't did it for years for
decades hugh hefner
playboy magazine he did it for years and
years and years
provided sources and hostesses for me
and you know what i'm saying
and it was all non-violent and wasn't
nobody forced to do it and the women
loved him for it
and that's that's for that companionship
that male companionship
and the same thing goes on in the
communities in the streets with players
and
and hookers they want that companionship
that security
that protection and that love because a
lot of girls man don't have it
you know being abused by fathers and
uncles and other men and to the point
that
they're destroyed emotionally destroyed
and psychologically destroyed
so they need a man to put them back
together so you take her you take her
and you make a butt naked and then you
reclose her
you throw them back grooming them right
but what what some of them
younger girls and younger pimps i think
are playing the game differently where
they
they are where the guys are are luring
them
in with telling the girls stories they
want to hear and then once they kind of
get them hooked then they
turn into i've been all the federal
prison pimpin
you know just recently in 2013 i was in
the mdc jail down here to federal jail
with guys
whom had trapped girls and kidnapped
girls and put them down and forced them
to do things sexually for for money and
that's a totally different perspective
about the pimping
than i had ever known it was sickening
to me
it was way out nasty might have been a
child molester right
because because the way you play it it's
not something disrespectful
it's a gift and it's a mental game
but but like mind control has been
mentioned yeah it's a middle game got to
know how to sex her mind
so you so that is part of your game yeah
did you put it back together
you know you you can't take someone
who's so psychologically damaged
and do anything with them until you
strip them and then re-fortify them with
strength and intelligence
and make them ladies are you building
their
somebody build up their self-worth and
all that all that
and after a few times you got their
opinion of themselves
and the psychological thing and their
opinions are men
you know once they find out that they're
beautiful that they are intelligent that
they're worth something
then they become a value to you too and
these these women are free to leave at
any point whenever they get ready
whenever they get ready and they're not
supposed to be with me and they leave
with a nice nest egg of money
yeah i've had them to leave and then
come back at a later date love me more
interesting yeah
i'm 74. you're 74. yeah
my first prostitute she's passing away
now she's in a coma
but all these years since the 60s too
now she's always been there for me
and so you would have how many girls in
your stable epic up to eight
and you'd have sex with all eight or yes
you would
yes and the girls would all understand
this and it's all just no problem
they would bring them to me other girls
who
love them and love me too
all the years that i've been in this
life that's been like that for me
it's artwork if you know how to do it
and you know how to love women and women
how to convince women to love you back
out of respect you get that so have you
been in love before
yes i have a wife now i love her
you're married yes she's 32 and she's
with me
she understands what you do and how you
do it and all that with me 100
we live in las vegas i dress down here
for family reunion thing
but we live in vegas we live with west
side northwest las vegas so we
in the gated community we live well and
your girls work the streets the
casinos casinos the streets and hotels
internet as well internet some little
internet work those who know how to
and when the girl gets arrested or
something i get them i'll go get them
you don't know
immediately go get them yeah and the
girls are all cool with you
yes none of them are being nobody being
manipulated or forced
my name rings the bell among them they
know they're going to be treated well
and they respect that out of me so you
they bring you 100 of the money each
night 100
and i take care of the family you do
what for them i take care of family
provide housing apartments and
clothes and whatever else that they
require
to the point of even you know those who
are still on their period
they got that coming so it's it's a
family situation
nobody's without the things that they
require to survive from day to day
so the way you play it you you're
claiming it's it's a
it's an offshoot of of the the way the
slavery relationships
existed many years ago yo it's not
it's not slavery it's not no no no but
you're what you're saying is the way
african-americans existed
because of slavery is kind of this is an
offshoot of that relationship
okay i accept that yeah i'm not saying
you're doing slavery i'm saying no
it's no no i'm saying it's uh derivative
of the way men and women
interacted back then yes because the
women were protecting the men that's
right
because the men were and it's still that
way today in the sense that
financially they are there to to make
sure that we all got enough
financing to take care of ourselves in
terms of physical protection
then i'm there but if you have eight
women or ten women
that leaves about seven or eight guys
that are without women
out there in the in the world the women
are normal men
they need they they need someone to be
with that's what makes people make
polygamy work there's more
more women than men in the world yeah
but not they don't have numbers eight to
one
about ten to one i think throughout the
world don't you think
ten times more women than men yes
sometimes something like that
something like that i'm not sure about
that statistic but
i'll i'll let you slide on that let me
slide well let's do this
check it out they're more i don't know
specifically
the percentage but there are more women
in the world than men
i i and that's what that may be way back
in biblical times
and that's why that's why abraham was
able to have all the women that he had
right i suspect that the successful
pimps
are high status males without a doubt
okay so you you have the ability to
attract eight or ten girls
without a problem whereas sometimes some
guys are sometimes even more
yeah and some guys just don't have the
the ability to do that right go ahead
and they get the scraps you don't have
the knowledge to do it
you know i see i see cats every day that
that are
forcing themselves on women uh don't
know how to talk to women asking for
something that they can't
ask for because they don't know how to
approach it
you see what i'm saying when you've got
guys like myself
who don't have a problem with the amount
of women that he can incorporate into
his life
then you see the difference between the
average cat that doesn't have the
knowledge and a cat like me who
all his lifetime has had nothing his
life been surrounded by women have you
ever had to get physical with a girl
no never no i refuse it when i get to a
point where the woman does that to me
to make me feel like that i leave her
alone she's not worth it
and there's many different styles to
this subculture yeah the gorilla pimps
there's the young uh
i call them tennis shoe pimps there's
yeah there's you know they're basically
gang members that are just
figuring out that you can make money off
these women you're right and those are
the ones that kids are getting hold to
today with
human trafficking right and that human
trafficking starts with 20 years
in prison federal prison i just left
from 2018
with people like that had that kind of
time you know i mean five or six
different cases
for five or six different women is that
upsetting to you to see that the
game has kind of turned into that yes it
is it's it's it's it's be
giving it a black eye because it's it's
so drastically different from where
from the stories that like fillmore slim
will tell or or yourself
right which is more of a gentlemanly
thing and the women are coming to you
and offering you this
this wonderful game to the young guys
that are just like
you know deceiving and tricking and
abusing
yeah abusing them but really and that's
and it's bad i've seen
up there i've seen women situate cases
where the women were burnt uh uh uh
kidnapped
held and root locked in rooms apartments
apartments
giving drugs turning out on drugs and
all that sort of stuff in order to get
them
to uh to work yeah i hear all these
stories
that's not good because you got to
constantly be on them
you know where where they at what they
doing you know i'm not
gonna you know pimp like that you know
what i mean girls get up and they know
it by five o'clock you get don't get
prepared themselves to go to work
i ain't got to tell them they know what
the schedule is when guys doing like
that
uh they're making just making it look
bad on guys who really professionally
pimping
and you your girls will make how much
money tonight well according to
what they're doing tonight some nights
are different than others
you know i've had them 2500 one girl but
that's
that's those nights that that uh they
have enough dates
and they pretty much know the dates
because there's schedule dates they
they've been dealing with for months and
years it just differs
is there a quota yeah normally fifteen
hundred to a thousand to fifteen hundred
dollars
a night but according to vegas is
different
than los angeles you know what i mean
you got a lot of males that come to
vegas purely for the girls
and it's a girls city so in a situation
like that they can get more money
in a run of the evening than they could
here in los angeles and you know i've
heard many
pimps and girls tell me stories about
how
finessing the guy out of his out of his
rolex watch or or his money out of his
wallet or something like that is is
a big part of the game yes if you know
how to do it i don't allow them to steal
i don't allow them to steal uh i don't
want somebody's watch
on somebody's id and all that kind of
crappy wallet
don't bring that to my house your game
is clearly a cell phone
because it's dangerous it can track the
phone and all that kind of stuff
and you end up with a bigger problem
because it turns horn into a robbery
horn into a burglary to a felony
and you've been doing this for many
decades yes i mean something
tell me a crazy story that you've seen
over the years
well i saw a little mama abused
in most situations the girl that i've
interviewed yeah you undergo
you know most situations her lifetime i
know of mom's like i said
uh she has been an abused girl and
manless you know and men would get her
because she was so
timid and so small and she 47 years old
she
still acts like she's a teenager a child
and i've seen her just used up man
really and that was bad
those times was about as bad as i've
seen it because i hated the people that
was doing it to her
i hated it let's see it i like to say i
saw her
two days ago me and my girl was coming
down fig
at 109th and she was walking down the
street and i caught her walk i said
i walked like little mama and she said
that is a little mama so i stopped her i
pulled over and turned
i turned around and went back and
stopped her and she said she was broke
and i gave her fifty dollars and sent
her on her way told her she needed me to
call me
because i had just heard maybe a week
before that some men had her on imperial
and avalon
uh raping her and abusing her and i
asked her about it
i told some people that told me that
this had happened was it true
and she denied that it had happened but
i know her
it happens to her all the time yeah
happens a lot of the girls
yeah but little mama i think it's a
little bit more than normal
it's such a dangerous lifestyle for the
girls or it's turned into that at least
maybe when you started that kind of
stuff was not happening but it certainly
is happening now
yeah almost every girl has a story of
some kind of kidnapping raping something
right
right back in the day they didn't have a
couple of holsters in this city
uh downtown here they had western and
adams
and the main one was uh the most potent
one was broadway and slauson around the
5-4
ballroom where the black musicians used
to entertain
you know the james browns and the tina
turners like them
um from there from 54 from broadway to
59th and broadway they called it
broadway and slow scenario
and uh and the speech was known and
and pimps and players would oh look out
for each other's hoes
you know if you wasn't there on the
stroll then the next pimp would make
sure that your girl got where she
was going and back before me and we
would take down likes and plate numbers
and stuff like that let you trick know
we we got your license plate number so
if you hurt her you're harm her we're
gonna see you
and that sort of thing nowadays it's not
like that girls are being butchered
i knew the guy that was killing all
those prostitutes some years back
the uh the grim weeper i used to live on
the same street which is doing on 80th
and
in western and he just went out the
street and killed he didn't kill girls
out to neighborhood
because his house stayed with
prostitutes that smoked crack
and he wasn't killing him he'd go
somewhere else and he had this finish
idea about killing women
but i knew that cat the grim sleeper
yeah
[Music]
yeah it seems like the gentleman the
gentlemanly way of doing of
playing this game is is is gone yes
and now it's it's a thug yes a lot of
pimps
graduated you know what i mean or
upgraded their game
they stopped hoeing stop lying bros a
hole for them
and start committing fraud you know
center them in banks and stuff like that
and so that protects them you know most
the females in my life from the past
are now playing khan or instead of
selling their bodies or playing con or
either
doing bank fraud have you done prison
time or yeah
before federal and state before what
fork fraud bank fraud
pimpin and pandering white slavery the
man act
federal
and what's the most important thing
you've learned in all your years of
doing this still
gentlemen i'm sorry to stay remain a
gentleman
to treat the game with respect because
if they treat you with respect back
you have a good name on the streets
it's important you know you cats live a
whole lifetime
you know offer their reputation and they
don't endanger it's like having a
million dollars in the bank for security
you know your security is your name your
reputation
among the girls and the guys in the game
it's important if you don't have a good
reputation then you nothing
not any speech nothing
you know my name rings bells all over
the country
for good game you know what i mean a
good game and people say man he's solid
when you get a name that not sucked and
people don't see you as being solid then
you're nothing
you know you might go on and cut your
throat commit suicide
if you're truly dedicated to this life
and you're not carrying it right
[Music]
excellent thank you so much for sharing
your story and okay giving us a little
bit of your wisdom
thank you for having me very nice thank
you very much
you